all right i think we are
ready for
the webinar today
please let me know in the chat section
if you can hear me well if you can see
me as well as if you can see my
presentation on the screen so
put in one or yes in the chat section so
that i can get the green light that we
are ready to
begin with today's exciting session and
that would be
my confirmation
that
i'm ready we are ready to go all right
so we have got the confirmation thank
you so much for
letting me know and once again
i welcome you all to today's webinar
and
to the
to another meeting of the scionix
student club for bioinformatics
enthusiasts
bioinformatics lovers students faculties
researchers all across the globe
it's my immense pleasure to welcome you
all today
and before we move on let me introduce
you to myself i am subrajeet maruva and
i am the president of the psionic
student club as well as i'm also the
scientific outreach coordinator at find
biotech
the vice president of this club is miss
ruth vivaja who unfortunately isn't
available today because of her exams but
she is also an active member of the
student club she has been
handling the club and working behind the
scenes for a long long time so
it's my pleasure to have her as my
teammate as well
so
let me briefly introduce you to omix and
the psionic student club well we are not
only a club but we are also a community
we are a family of more than 1 000
students from all across the globe from
different countries different areas
we also have a huge community of experts
from who are expertized in different
backgrounds and they always help us
assist us train us to become the better
version of ourselves in the domain of
bioinformatics computational biology and
biology in general
we are also proud of our very strong
alumni network
who have been a part of the psionics
club for a long long time
they have
trained themselves in bioinformatics
they have learned the skills and how
they are making an impact all around the
world in different areas and domains
and we are really proud of that rich
network of alumni in our club
so
what is the vision of psionics the
bioinformatics club well
at psionics we are
really interested in
different areas or applications of
bioinformatics and computational biology
to name a few we are interested in
infectious diseases microbes and
microbiome precision oncology plant
science neuroscience and even the very
recent and exciting field of
astrobiology or space omics
so
the club psionics is focused and driven
towards clearing concepts of
bioinformatics to help one another gain
insights on how to use a bioinformatics
tool
to learn to apply these techniques in
research in day-to-day life we have
brainstorming sessions to help one
another grow and enhance in life we also
have sessions on coding skills and also
on data science like we are having today
at siomx in the past we have also had
some sessions which were dedicated to
help the students get better in their
academics to apply abroad study abroad
programs how to refine your cv how to
refine your curriculum vitae and resume
and how to crack an interview are some
of the other non-conventional topics
which we also cover at scionx so if you
feel that this is something which you
are interested in and you would like to
be a part of us please consider joining
us and staying with us
we you are always welcome moving forward
you will hear the word omics logic a lot
so i think it's
mandatory for me to introduce what
comics logic is
well omixlogic is
a community or an initiative
which is aimed at creating and providing
good quality training in bioinformatics
which enables the
trainees the ones who get the training
to be enabled to do independent research
guided by mentors and pure examples
comics logic is also focused towards
developing a growing community such as
this one psionics with the shared
passion for data-driven research and
appreciation of citizen science research
as well and finally we also enable
students clinicians and faculties from
all backgrounds to develop new
techniques new tools and algorithms
which can be applied in life science
research
moving forward
well now i would like to briefly
introduce you to the upcoming omics
research symposium that is going to
happen on march 31st and april 1st
this is an international conference
which is an exciting opportunity for
all of you to be a part of
this particular
symposium is held by annually that is
twice a year which brings together
the huge community that omixlogic has
produced which includes students
faculties industrial experts
together on the same platform to discuss
the latest trends the latest
advancements the cutting-edge research
their outcomes as well as to discuss
what are the various opportunities what
are the areas of concerns and how to
improve
students can really gain
insights about what industries are
looking for in a student what is it that
takes a student to get place to get
their dream job and a lot of more
interesting information
this time at naomi's research symposium
we have experts from the academia from
leading universities such as amit
university
georgetown university and many other top
universities of the world we have
industrial partners and speakers from
organizations such as google nasa ames
research center blue marble space papa
academy destroyer another alliance lower
nord disk and many more and also we have
experts from our network partners which
include lvrn nepti
h3a bionet and many more
so here i would briefly want to talk
about what is it that the universities
are looking for well they are looking
for involving capable students in
exciting and cutting-edge research they
are looking for placements for students
that's one of the end goal of
universities to enable their students
get placed in reputed organizations and
also to perform translational research
that is a research from lab to the
market that is something which
industries i mean the universities are
looking for what are the industries or
the companies looking for well they're
looking for students to provide
internship co-ops and trainings
they are also looking for potential
employees both young career
opportunities as well as experienced
employees are something which
industrious are constantly looking
forward to and also they these
industries have a lot of outreach
programs a lot of training resources
that they have made so they want to get
those people who can benefit from these
resources so how can the omics research
symposium help all the three parties
well
this is a platform as i said that brings
together experts from both industries
and academia on a common platform
we also have a large audience of
students from all across the globe with
diver skill sets who will be a part of
this symposium and this symposium brings
an opportunity for networking and
getting to know each other better to
discuss various opportunities and to
proceed ahead in life
so what's unique about the students who
are a part of omixlogic psionics and who
are also going to be a part of the omics
resource symposium well these students
belong to great universities from all
across the globe and these universities
are the universities that are partners
to us we are in constant touch with them
and we know the training
standards the training modules our
students have a fine understanding of
mathematics tools and concepts that they
have gained by going through the various
course materials available
on the omix logic platform that you can
also access
at your end to get trained in
bioinformatics and our students also
know how to apply these
techniques and tools and that can be
seen when they present their post
representations
more on poster presentation in just a
while
so here's a sneak peek into some of the
great speakers lined up for the omix
research symposium 2022 you can find
speakers from different backgrounds with
different levels of expertise all
connected through bioinformatics and big
data science together on this common
platform so
if you find this interesting do check it
out and do make sure to register for the
symposium now apart from listening to
these expert stocks and
various cutting-edge research and
advancements there's also another
component of the symposium which is a
post representation competition this is
your opportunity for the students and
researchers to showcase your projects
your experiences just like these
projects as you can see on the screen
which were the ones which won the prizes
the cash prizes last time in the
previous symposium so here you can see
examples of posters made by high school
students by undergraduates who not only
learned about bioinformatics got trained
in bioinformatics and also understood
how to apply these techniques in solving
some research problems which is a real
world problems how to deal with data how
to analyze them how to understand the
results and present it as a poster so
that is the entire idea of organizing
these webinars organizing all the
programs and modules and finally to
showcase all of these exciting results
in the symposium this time we have four
categories in which you can submit your
posters namely omix and bioinformatics
artificial intelligence machine learning
and data science astrobiology and
spaceonics and computational biology for
biotech and pharmaceuticals
the best posters will walk away with
cash prizes segregated into three
different categories namely best poster
presentation this citizen science
project and young sheldon award for high
school researchers
so
you must be wondering what's the
procedure of
doing such projects how is the best way
to overcome challenges maybe you are
working on something but you are facing
some issues with data handling or
applying some tools and techniques
what is it that the judges of these
poster presentations would be looking
for
from these posters
well that is why we have with us mr dark
of merit today who is a data scientist
and an artificial intelligence
statistics expert
who is also the
judge of the post representation
competition of the symposium so today
mr darko meridian will be talking about
bioinformatics and data science
challenges and what are the ways to
address them and how you can overcome
these challenges complete your project
and present in this poster presentation
competition
and what is it that he as the judge of
this poster presentation competition is
expecting from the students from the
posters and what according to him is the
best way to present a poster so that the
participants can walk away with the
exciting prizes
so without any further ado it gives me
immense pleasure to welcome to the stage
today mr darko marin and i would let you
take over from this moment
thank you very much sir project
and
as you said
i will be
talking about bioinformatics and data
science challenges today
but also sharing some tips
for future
bioinformatics experts
on how to resolve certain problems how
to
[Music]
overcome certain obstacles in let's say
data science
and be more successful
in
bioinformatics
career
as suprajet mentioned
i am a data scientist
with
previous
experience
in
[Music]
conducting different research
i was former program manager for
time biotech
data science programs and i will also be
one of the judges
at the
upcoming comics logic research symposium
poster
presentation competition
so
i will uh
focus on
different aspects of challenges
that may arise during
during
bioinformatics research and
applying data science to overcome these
challenges so this is the main focus of
today's
session
before
i actually start
addressing different challenges
i must think about
where these challenges arise from
what is bioinformatics what are the
domains where bioinformatics is applied
so
some of bioinformatics challenges
are
actually related
as we can see from the name by
informatics biology so we have the
bio prefix
in word bioinformatics
it's clear that
biology is one of the topics
that is of interest
but not just biology
bioinformatics
is a very
diverse
set
of
uh
interdisciplinary programs
or areas of science
which is related not just to biology but
also to other sciences like
chemistry
or physics
biomedicine
and clinical research so
when i say bio
in bioinformatics
i don't mean just about biology there
are many other
sciences
which are related to bioinformatics
what is in common for all these
sciences
is
that they are somehow related to
a life science so we can say that
bioinformatics
is an
interdisciplinary program or
interdisciplinary set of
research methods
which are
related to
a very diverse
spectrum of life sciences so
this brings me to
challenge number one
which is
knowing
the domains
of life sciences
where
bioinformatics is applied
i will give a few examples
uh supergit mentioned some of them
earlier like oncology oncology is
related to molecular biology it's
related to biomedicine it's related to
clinical
research too it's related to genetics so
a lot of different domains are
uh
connected to this one aspect of
bioinformatics there are many other
areas of bioinformatics like evolution
like plant biology like studying
different molecules
studying for example proteins and
what happens with the chemistry and
physics of proteins
so
identifying these challenges
is very important
in terms of understanding
where these challenges lie in which
domains
of life science
of course
having domain knowledge
is one of the essential parts
of any research project
and the
research project should have a detailed
description
of
these domains
on the other hand these domains are
important because they're also included
in the interpretation of results in
understanding
what these results mean
so bioinformatics results
are not just
uh
some numbers or graphs
they are related
to real
life science problems
and uh
ways to address these problems okay
so uh
to
address these problems
to resolve these
life science challenges
which
bioinformatics is used for
there is a diverse
set of methods and tools
which is uh utilized
to achieve better results and to resolve
some of these challenges
some of them are genetic algorithms
this automatically
tells me
that
genetics is one of the main domains
in bioinformatics
machine learning
is another
set of tools and methods
used to resolve
various
bioinformatics challenges
data science
as mentioned before
is of course related to both of these
areas
and is another set of
methods and
different approaches
to resolve bioinformatic challenges
sequence alignments logically if we are
talking about genetics
we're talking about
sequences of dna
so
sequence alignment algorithms and
methods is another set of tools used in
bioinformatics
and
in the end but not less important
statistics statistics is a set of
methods used to analyze and interpret
results
that are
achieved during the research project
one thing which is very important is
that
most of these methods are applied to a
certain type of data in bioinformatics
and this type of data is a
mostly originating from molecular
biology
so
i can say it's mostly
dna rna
proteins different sequences from other
molecules so molecular level of biology
on the other hand it's not limited to
molecular biology there are
many other
biological
types of data which are
included in bioinformatics
so
as i said before it's a very wide
spectrum of different domains and
methods
uh that are applied in the
bioinformatics so
one of the main challenges of course is
understanding this variety of methods
and challenges
one thing that is in common for
all these methods
is that they rely on data
so
these methods are actually
related to data
and computer science so we can say
that it's a
data-driven set of tools and methods
where computer science
enables
to
uh have
different solutions
for all the challenges
that i spoke about before from those
life science domains
so challenge number two
of course
is related to data
as you can see all the methods are
related to data so understanding how
these methods could be applied
to uh different uh research projects of
course requires to
focus on the data and understand
the data that is included in the project
as i said most of this data comes from
molecular biology so understanding the
data of course
requires understanding molecular biology
to a certain extent
so challenge
number two
would be
challenge related to understanding the
data and focusing on the data
on the other hand understanding these
tools these algorithms
and
how to
utilize them on different types of data
how to get the best results and
by doing that how to resolve those
challenges
so
here is an uh
explanation of uh
one very important area of molecular
biology
how information is transferred from
dna from genes
to proteins which are biologically
active substances
so
[Music]
there is a certain flow of information
from genes
there is a process called transcription
where these sequences are read and
information passed from dna to messenger
rna and then at the end proteins are
created
by certain type of coding where
three
uh three
nucleotides code different
amino acids so this was just one example
of how understanding certain domain of
molecular biology is important because a
lot of data
molecular biology and bioinformatics is
actually
dna sequences rna sequences proteins etc
so
why would we uh
need to understand these uh domains
of molecular biology well here is an
example of how
dna variation
is very important in understanding uh
cancer or
understanding uh
how
cancer develops how it's treated and
what are the potentials
uh in developing future therapies and uh
understanding the principles of cancer
development
so
here's just an explanation of
how mutations for example
can
alter the functions of proteins
which may lead to
uh different changes in cells and dna
which are related to cancer so
understanding these changes
understanding these changes in genetic
information
is
essential in cancer bioinformatics
understanding types of mutations how
they affect the proteins
is one of the examples of how knowing
the domain in which research is done
is essential
in conducting the actual bioinformatics
project
of course
these
molecular biology segments
should be defined
in detail
in every research projects related
to these areas of bioinformatics so
explaining them in a very concise way
that everyone can expl anyone can
understand
on the other hand explaining them in a
way
which uh covers
all important areas of a research
project
is
one of the
uh let's say tips that i can share
for for this
part of my information
to understand
what bioinformatics challenges are
i will first need to understand and
explain
some similar areas
of life sciences and
computer science
one such area is called computational
biology
so as it can be seen
there is
life science domain knowledge as i
previously explained
there are some scientific goals
associated
with this
life science domain knowledge
but this time
there are theoretical models and
computational simulations so
computational biology
is
mostly
focused on
simulations and theoretical models
on the other hand
bioinformatics
is focused on
real data
originating from life science
experiments
from laboratories
and
statistics and data science
are applied
to
analyze this data to derive insights
from this data
one thing that is in common for
uh these boxes that i uh
painted in yellow here so life science
real data statistics and data science
they're
both applied sciences so
they are sciences
used to resolve challenges originating
from the real world from real
experiments
and as such having data originating from
them as a real day
statistics
on the other hand
is a
part of science which was developed by
mathematicians
that wanted to apply mathematics
on real life challenges so it's another
form of applied science and that is one
of the aspects of bioinformatics
it is of course very practical
data derived from experiments is
real laboratory data
and
this brings me to another challenge
which is
to understand the practical aspects
of
working
with bioinformatics challenges
one of the best ways
to
learn these aspects is
as was
mentioned previously in one of the
programs
find biotech by
by uh
mr ilia brotzky
is
learn by doing that is one of the best
ways to learn a certain method to
understand this method to understand the
whole project is to actually perform the
project so learn by doing would be
another tip
that i can mention
in this in this moment
to
continue with the whole story of
data-driven science so bioinformatics is
data genetic science
i will first go back to some
moments in history so
here uh
what is presented is a
number of researchers that
actually discovered the
structure of dna in 1950s
and
of course
from 1990s
a
human genome project actually
improved many
areas of bioinformatics
the amount of data was
increasing gradually with development of
different
different
types of
laboratory experiments different types
of instruments
able to sequence
genes proteins etc etc
what is very interesting is that as time
moves on
in past few decades there is a very very
strong increase in the number of
sequence genomes
in the amounts of bioinformatic data
available
so uh as you can be seen from 2015 there
is very very very
uh high increase in the amount of
bioinformatic data available
why is this important
i previously said that bioinformatics is
data-driven
uh science
if it's data-driven that means
that
when there is more data
if the amount of data is increasing
that means that possibilities
and development of bioinformatics
is also
improved
when i say
data has increased
data has increased to such a level
to such an amount
that there is an actual term to describe
these large amounts of data
that are present today
it's called big data
now big data and large amounts of data
of course
uh
have
different challenges that accompany them
so
with development of big data also
different challenges arise
and
a data scientist or bioinformatician
needs
needs to have a
different set of solutions which are
mostly ip solutions to resolve these
challenges
so
one challenge is data comes from
different sources
huge amounts of data are created all
around the world
at different labs
they're stored in different repositories
so different sources mean
that they will definitely have different
characteristics so one of the challenges
is how to resolve this this
uh big difference
how to address this big difference that
exists with
uh within these sources and between them
of course
another aspect is noise
large amounts of data produce large
amounts of noise
so
this is another challenge that needs to
be addressed
a large storage requirements
if large amount of data is created
it has to be stored somewhere
this storage requires
hardware
disk space
cloud space different solutions where
this data can be processed stored and
then accessed
when the
computation power
to analyze huge amounts of data
using very complex algorithms that i
mentioned before like machine learning
computation power
needs to
be there
to
support these analyses
so computational power is one of the
challenges as the amount of data
increases
uh
and
different types of complex methods are
applied to this large amount of data
computation power must also increase
in the end structure
structure means that
there must be a specific way this data
is stored
so that future researchers
uh can
easily access and access it
there must be a set of rules
this data is stored by
and
we can call that a structure okay
i mentioned repositories before so these
are the places
where
data is stored
these places
also
must
follow
the increased demands for storing large
amounts of data
over the past few years
a lot of these repositories where data
is stored
have
become open
to
all researchers around the world
to utilize them in different research
projects so i think uh
understanding and knowing how to
navigate these uh platforms is very
important some of them
are mentioned here like ncbi tcga mbl
dpj uh uci etc etc
uh
i will explain uh some of these uh
briefly so ncbi is a
u.s uh
repository for
storing the large amounts of
bioinformatic data tcga
is also
uh
used uh in similar fashion uh it's
mostly focused on
tumors
uh embl european molecular biology
repository is uh
also uh used to store
large amounts of uh bioinformatic data
and it's uh
open uh
it's open in large quantities uh to
researchers around the world
ddbj is another repository from japan
uci machine learning repository etc etc
so uh one of the challenges uh in uh
data science is acquiring data right so
having open database repositories uh
makes that challenge much much easier to
resolve
so that's another tip uh for me
uh to
uh know how to
use these open responsibilities how to
navigate these platforms how to access
the data
so um
that's pretty much it for for for this
part on data advisories
now to
understand the data
i said before that focus should be in
the data
we first need to understand where this
data comes from okay it comes from life
science domains
but uh
what are the instruments to use what are
the labs used uh used to create this
data so
here you can see on the right side one
sequencer which is used to
actually create
sequence data from different molecular
biology samples
but there is another uh
aspect so definitely understanding the
instruments where data comes from is
important and generally every uh
every larger project
even the
even the projects that are that don't
belong to large studies
should generally have
a detailed explanation about
what instruments uh data came from what
are the characteristics of this
instrument maybe what are limitations of
the instruments etc etc
but there is another uh
technical aspect that is not that much
discussed
uh in bioinformatics communities i think
it should be discussed much more
which is
understanding
the computer hardware why
well
for a bioinformatician
computer is his life
that's the tool
that uh his or her lab
as i said that's the tool
that is used by most implementation
bioinformaticians
to resolve
certain uh bioinformatics challenges so
focusing just on other aspects without
understanding
the very
tool
uh
used
for
direct bioinformatics analysis which is
of course a laptop or a computer
or a super computer some some labs have
special super computers to use for
bioinformatics challenges
uh is uh
it's essential to understand
uh the
hardware needs
for a computer
let me give an example
analyzing large amounts of data
maybe requires
a processor
that
can support this analysis
sometimes
to speed up
bioinformatic analysis
data scientists use
parts of
computers
which are called
graphic cards or gpus to speed up the
process
then
large data sets sometimes require large
amounts
of storage space on a computer
so understanding all these aspects
is critical so
another tip that i would
share is
it's of course important to know
all the aspects of uh life science
domains
to understand two
methods but it's also important
to understand the computer components
needed to perform a certain analysis
okay
learning about sequences sequencing
instruments as i said before is
important because
they're generally part of the research
project
so to understand the quality of the data
we need to understand
the instruments that derive this data
where this data is created
okay now i talked about
hardware parts
now let me transfer to
one aspect which is not related to
actual
hardware to instruments and
computers which is the software part or
uh
how is this data
store stored in computers which formats
here we have uh present we can see uh
different formats presented by sq fasta
gtf sambam these are all
uh file formats
i will just make a parallel here uh for
everyone to be uh
easier to understand
we have different file formats on
computer like word formats excel files
uh
images uh bitmap images for example
these are all file formats in
bioinformatics
there are also different formats
that need to be understood for a
practical application uh
of a research uh
research experiment analysis and then of
course finishing the research project
it's not very frequent that these file
formats are included
in research projects but to be able to
practically conduct the analysis it's
essential to understand these formats
what is fastq format what is fasta for
example
i'm just going to give a very short
explanation
fastq files are used to store
sequences of let's say rna
but not just the sequences also the
amounts of expression
for different uh rna sequences on the
other hand faster file is used just to
store sequences right there is no
expression there is just sequence
information so understanding these very
very
specific differences
means that
[Music]
researchers understand
understands
the actual data that is stored
in those files
another
example is if someone is to
perform
[Music]
let's say uh rna expression analysis
uh
he or she should use a fast q file
but if a bioinformatics researcher uh is
performing just sequence analysis for
example mutations
uh pasta files are one of the choices
there are other files like
vcf5ztc which are similar
that could be used so
uh i would just uh give another tip
which is it's important to understand
the file formats that's that's another
important uh
aspect okay so here is one of those uh
one of those uh
formats that i mentioned before which is
vcf file
uh so
it has a certain
metadata
which is not related to these
uh
these parts of the data essential for
the analysis but it's important to know
this metadata
often contains information about
what type of the data
is used in the research sometimes about
instruments about experimental
conditions so it's important not to
forget
information contained in the metadata
okay
so
using different formats is essential to
understand
now
next step once the data is
understood in detail
and this
let me call it a
data understanding challenge
is the result
next step is to actually analyze this
data
to analyze the data
different set of methods are applied
in fact
most
bioinformatics analysis
are
performed in a way that multiple of
these
methods are used
on different types of data
so they form something which is called a
bioinformatics pipeline
this is an example of using server t bio
info which is a fine biotech platform
for creating these pipelines
this is an example
of how
uploading the data and then using
a certain algorithm called bauti by
baotai and then using
gtf processing visualization
is used to actually visualize
uh visualize first map
map the data on the genome and then
visualize
using different algorithms
so
this
is essential for another
area of the informatics bioinformatics
which is understanding the pipelines how
can these pipelines be constructed uh
all of these methods must be compatible
one with another and they also must be
compatible with the type of the data
which is used so this is another uh
tip i would share which is
define the analysis pipeline in a way
that functions of these methods are
compatible with each other
okay
so uh
here's another uh example
which is mutational analysis
i mentioned before
that mutations are for example very
important in cancer research
so here is here is a pipeline that uses
pcr claim balti
uh strelka etc dc to actually
uh
create a certain uh analysis which is
related to
discovering mutations
or variants in this case
uh in the day
okay so
once the pipelines
are
created once they are defined
and
i will just repeat this again
pipeline of these methods is another
important uh
important part to define in any research
project related to bioinformatics
once that is finished
there is another step which is called
interpretation so as you can see here
there is
a graph with different colors and
different
hierarchies different lines there are a
lot of details
in these graphs
so uh
how to make
this
result
easily readable
to
any audience
to
researchers who are not
bioinformaticians who don't understand
all of these concepts that we were
talking about is another challenge so
interpreting the results should be
a process where
the results are presented in a way for
anyone
to easily read
to be understandable
to a
wide spectrum of audience so i'll just
give an example the left graph has uh
two very distinct groups one which is
colored in red so we can see that
there is uh
there is a number of these uh samples
which are
very high uh in expression of certain
gene and then there is another blue
group here which has a lower lower
expression of certain genes so
using a very simple way
to explain to anyone
uh what a certain result tells us
is one very important challenge in
mindfulness
so
as i said before there are many ways of
presenting results the key is presenting
them in such a way that is easily easily
understood
okay
so
as i said before some of the tips
are to actually
understand
how to
explain
the noise how to explain some solutions
to that
noise which is present in large data
sets and how to correct certain biases
which may uh may be contained in the
date okay
so
this brings me
to a challenge which is uh
more of importance for people
who are interested in pursuing a
bioinformatics or data science career
which is uh knowing
uh
different programming language now of
course these pipelines that i shown
before are meant to facilitate
bioinformatics analysis without actually
knowing
how to program in different
different programming languages but
knowing these languages is a plus
because it allows scientists
uh to actually
customize the analysis
customize these outputs visualizations
see it's best to know both it's best to
understand how to create different
pipelines let's say on a
uh platform like a key buying book but
also understand these programming
languages to be able to customize the
analysis to customize
some output cpc is
okay
so
r and python which can be seen here
are
some of the programming they're actually
the most popular programming languages
used in uh bioinformatics analysis so
these are some of my recommendations for
any future
data scientists or bioinformaticians
to actually try to understand these
languages as much as possible
now
with uh
development of a
large amount of
repositories and data
there is also development of novel
methods
methods that are very advanced
and
can
efficiently
be used to resolve different
bioinformatics challenges
one of these methods for example is
called deep learning right so deep
learning
is a
set of methods used that uses uh
artificial intelligence
in a way
that
different algorithms are
being used in a similar
fashion
to that of a human brain
to actually learn from the data
and learn different patterns
to be able to predict different uh
outcomes etc etc
so
there are different platforms like
tensorflow python or gpc i will not be
uh
i will mention these is very important
uh but as i said this is something for
future data scientists
to uh actually keep in mind it's also
used in bioinformatics research uh very
extensively in fact
so that's one of the areas i can
recommend
for for
future bioinformaticians
now
some key concepts
that
i would actually
mention from this last part which is
interpreting data is simplify the
complexity when interpreting
and
teach a data story
being a good data interpreter
is like being a good
data store storyteller so you must
actually teach
this story to someone who
hasn't been included uh
in the research to
teach it in a way that is easily
understandable
to anyone uh
anyone reading about
uh the research project is okay
i know that uh
we don't really have too much uh time so
i'll just leave this large last part of
the session for
suprajit for questions
related to any other areas
thank you so much darko that was an
amazing
presentation today amazing session
i'm sure all of us learned a lot of
things about
the different
aspects of bioinformatics data science
and
next generation sequencing technologies
and also the various methods and ways to
address
all the challenges and difficulties
which we might face in our day-to-day
projects so on behalf of the entire
team of cyamics i would really like to
thank you for your time and your great
presentation
it has been a pleasure to have you here
with us today thank you so much darko
you're welcome and uh
it has been really a pleasure for me to
[Music]
conduct this workshop and
thank you very much for inviting me as a
guest speaker
so
i hope
that the workshop has
helped
address many challenges and
please let me know if there are any
questions from
from students or
any other
aspects that should be discussed
thank you so much darko so
to our audience today if you have any
questions regarding
bioinformatics data science whatever
our guest spoke about today
or if you have any questions regarding
poster presentation
um the symposium
and other training opportunities and
courses please feel free to put your
questions in the chat section
and i will definitely take up all those
questions and will try my best to answer
you
and
while you are typing your questions
thinking about it i i would like to
remind you about some exciting
opportunities and
possibilities in the near future
so in the month of march
we at pine biot economics logic have
organized several workshops
and
webinars for you to join and benefit to
learn about different popular terms
cutting edge technologies in today's
generation
so as you can see on your screen we have
a very
interesting workshop coming up on march
15 to 17 which is on machine learning
and omics data analysis which is
something that is really
like
really related to what we were talking
today what we learned from target today
so applying machine learning for doing
this big data comics analysis is
something which we will be covering on
march 15th to 17th
then we have a special faculty and
mentor workshop where they will be
talking about several specializations
which includes precision medicine
infectious diseases neuroscience
oncologists fake stomachs agriculture ai
and drug discovery and
what sort of approach we take at our
mixed logic that is the project-based
training modules will be discussed in
this workshop so you can also attend it
to get a flavor of what we are trying to
do and achieve
then
on march 22 we will be having a detailed
analysis of cancer mutations using next
generation sequencing
workshop where
you can learn about the various
algorithms the various pipelines and the
various tools and techniques that we use
here to provide a detailed analysis of
cancer biology
and then analyze the next generation
sequencing data
finally all of this workshops and
efforts lead up to the mega event of
this month that is the omics research
symposium that is going to happen on
march 31st and april 1st 2022
you can find the registration links in
the chat it's completely free to be a
listener to
join and listen to all the
talks by the great speakers and the
panelists lined up you can find the link
to the schedule as well in the chat so
that you can get an idea of the timing
all timings are provided in indian
standard time greenwich mean time and
central daylight savings time so you can
adjust according to your time zone
and also if you're interested in
submitting your project as a post
representation you can find the call for
abstract
link in the chat and the deadline for
submitting your abstract is march 20. it
is an extended deadline the previous
deadline was march 10 but due to the
overwhelming response the great amount
of submissions and requests from the
students we have decided to decided to
extend it for 10 more days
so that all of you can participate in it
i will be talking more about it later
but
we have one question in the chat section
so i would pick it up
the question is from rizzy makoka
and the question is
would it require one to understand all
the intertwined aspects in order to
better answer biological question or
would it require the use of a
multidisciplinary approach in a team
setup to solve this
so darko if you would like to answer
this question basically uh how much or
what are the various different types of
techniques and skills required to answer
a biological question is it necessary
for one individual to be expertised in
different
factors or sectors or it is better to
work in a multi-disciplinary team where
different people are expertized in
different segments so what do you think
darwin
uh thank you very much to credit and uh
thank you very much uh rishi for the
question it's a very interesting
question
uh and it's present not just in
bioinformatics but also
in data science
the parts of science where a lot of
research projects that i have performed
previously
uh
over in question so very interesting
question bioinformatician as you have
seen from the presentation
uh bioinformatics and its challenges are
a very
uh wide uh
spectrum
of different types of science so biology
biomedicine
data science machine learning computer
science
statistics
very often these analysis are conducted
in
multi-disciplinary teams so
there are computer scientists their data
scientists their biologists medical
doctors etc but for a bioinformatician
it's important to know all these aspects
to a certain level now
uh no one can really know
uh these uh these
multi
multi-dimensional
approaches
uh to every sin uh
to a level where every single detail is
covered but
there is a level
where it's important to understand all
these aspects because
bioinformaticians
often serve as a bridge between
i mean bridge in a symbolic way
uh between different branches of science
like biology medical doctors
computer scientists software engineers
so definitely the question is uh great
and uh
some summary of this answer would be
it is important to know all these
domains to a certain level
uh
to a level where a bioinformatician
may serve as a certain communication uh
bridge
between all these sciences
thank you so much darko that's a great
explanation and a great answer to the
question and i hope that
really answers you
your question thank you so much darko
for
sharing your thoughts and answering this
question
so
moving forward this is
all about the homicide symposium here's
the qr code to register
for the symposium we are just a few days
away from this mega event so if you
haven't registered already please
scan this qr code you can also find the
links in the chat we'll register for the
all mixed resistant pushermen we would
be really grateful to see you at the
symposium
so as i was also mentioning about the
poster presentations for students and
researchers
the four categories once again to
reiterate are omics and bioinformatics
artificial intelligence machine learning
and data science projects astrobiology
and spaceonics and computational biology
in the biotechnology and pharmaceuticals
there are
several exciting prizes to be won
the deadline was march 10th but it has
been extended on popular request and the
new deadline is march 20 that is a
10-day extension for submission of your
abstracts here are the rules for
submitting your abstracts
make sure that the length is 150 to 200
words
and it should consist of the following
segments like objective methods results
and conclusion
the font size should be 12 and the font
style should be monster at and please
convert it into a pdf file and then
upload on our server so
when you scan this particular qr code
you will be redirected to our website
where you can get the form so fill it up
and upload your abstract and we will
analyze and get back to you through
email very very soon
so
pine biotech is
has a global presence and you can find
us all on
almost every social media platform
so
it is a very good idea to stay in touch
with us because we constantly keep
sharing a lot of information a lot of
updates and various insights
you can find all the links to the
various social media handles
on
the chat so make sure to
follow us
on all the social media handles and also
join our videos groups we have groups on
facebook on linkedin so in these groups
we have various experts
and and students from all over the world
so you can interact with them
communicate with them network with them
so please make sure to do that as well
and finally you can also share your
feedback with us by scanning this qr
code and
sharing your insights with us about how
you felt in this webinar what are the
various areas that you believe in which
we can improve and all your comments and
views will be really appreciated that's
the way which motivates us to keep doing
this every week
so that brings us to the end of today's
great great psionics webinar it was
amazing to have all of you with us today
once again on behalf of the entire team
of cyanics we would like to thank our
guest mr darko madden it was a very
insightful and experi and we learned a
lot
from your talk today and we hope to keep
learning from you in the days to come
also thank you to everyone for joining
us today in this journey we will again
see you
in the next week with another exciting
topic another exciting theme with
another great speaker and a great guest
till then make sure to stay in touch
with us through
all the channels that we have feel free
to send your email to me if you want my
email id is
communications at the ratepine.bio i'm
putting it down in the chat section you
can send me an email if you want to
communicate anything with me i will be
more than happy to answer you
so if you have any questions feel free
to put it down in the chat otherwise
that's
a curtain call from us today and we will
see you again soon take care and stay
safe thank you so much for everyone for
joining and we will see you soon
thank you sir
thank you everyone and uh best of luck
uh in the symposium and uh competition
to everyone
thank you so much darko for your support
thank you